number of U.S home sales plunges to
lowest level since 2012. number of U.S
home plunges to lowest level since 2012.
um so number of homes available for
selling units on May 2 announced a
filled by with some point one percent
previous year the first annual declines
since April of 2020 to reducing
availability to its lowest level since
2012 Redfin which reported the data
States nearly every homeowner with a
mortgage has an interest rate below six
percent meaning many are opting to stay
put because selling and buying a new
home would mean taking on a higher
monthly mortgage payment housing
affordability continues to be a major
concern with the median price of an
existing single family home rising from
three hundred thousand dollars in 2020
to 393 thousand dollars in April of
2023. this has caused the mortgage
payment as a percentage of increase to
jump 14.7 percent to 26 percent let me
read that one more time this has caused
the mortgage payment as a percentage of
income to jump from 14.7 percent of your
income to twenty six percent of your
income which by the way that's always
what I go to when these Realtors and
mortgage officers are like well let me
tell you you know your home prices are
this and no if affordability is
something you have to be thinking about
and and Tom the guy that gave us a
report at the elite Mastermind that we
had the report that he gave Vinnie in
2021 realtors in California Brokers
realtors in California made 18 billion
dollars in Commissions in 2021. 18
billion 18 billion dollars in
commissions that dropped to 9 billion
the following year okay nine billion
dollars of the following years how much
commission they've made which means
there's not a lot of inventory to sell
the prices may be held up but there's
not enough inventory to sell Tom when
you see the story what do you think
about well what I think about is on its
face that's exactly what we're saying
and what this gentleman pointed out and
some information out that I was digging
in
um you know a year ago I thought
interest rates could get to 10 I
remember I said it on this podcast they
got up to seven seven and a half percent
and they've they've kind of mellowed a
little bit but it's a sustained it's not
just a spike it's not coming back down
and the interest rate is exactly what is
driving this that but if if I was to
some let's say I had to move from
Nashville and I had to move to you know
uh Plantation
um I look at it and say well if I sell
my house in Nashville and then buy a
house in Plantation you know seven
percent interest rates I'm screwed so
you know what people are doing I will
lease the house with this three percent
um interest rate in Nashville and I'm
just gonna go lease a house in South
Florida because I probably even if I
sold in Nashville I probably wouldn't be
able to afford to buy the house so
what's happening is the supply is stuck
this is called the stuck supply problem
where people even if their job forces
them to move their Airbnb or they're
keeping their house in the previous
Market because as a low interest rate
and they want to preserve that interest
rate by the way it's also got property
tax based on the purchase value way back
when and if they bought that house in
Florida they're going to be buying at a
higher purchase price so their property
tax is going to be up in addition to the
um actual payment so we have a supply
problem that is keeping prices High and
the high mortgage rates is causing the
supply to be low because no one wants to
sell their houses
I'll flip it for you Pat can we go to
San Francisco just one second home
prices are down 17 in San Francisco why
is that I'll tell you why because Supply
is coming up why is Supply coming up
because people are leaving and why are
people leaving because of the jobs in
the city and the policies in San
Francisco so when you have intervening
factors in San Francisco that are
causing people to actually say you know
what I am selling and I am leaving the
supply comes up and the prices come down
despite the mortgages so there's a I
won't dive into it but there's a blue
city mayor you know case study to be
done here of what they've done that's
causing people to actually sell at this
time no matter what and so prices are
coming down in San Francisco but on a
market level
the supply is going to remain stuck for
a little while here because the FED is
saying uh in their last uh report they
may raise a little bit at the end of
July like another quarter point but they
don't see a a steady reduction in rates
for two years I'll add one thing to that
I mean we all know in basic economics
the law of supply and demand it's the
number one thing you should understand
but it's hard to gauge that just looking
at it like what's the supply what's the
man but what you can gauge if you're an
average person out there
is this home or this car or this asset
is it cheap or is it expensive and
that's something that you could eyeball
and be like all right yeah I can afford
that that sounds like a good deal or
holy how the hell am I gonna afford
something like this so do that it's hard
for you to eyeball supply and demand
like in San Francisco but it's very easy
for the average person
uh to understand whether you're getting
a good deal on something or whether
you're paying an arm and a leg and these
days people completely understand that
they're paying an arm and a leg for
homes out there because the supply is
not exactly where it it could be or it's
not very high and
um prices are
unbelievably high and this is what we've
said for a while so people are asking
well what do I do right now what's in it
for me I'll tell you what's in it for
you it's in a few if you're in a market
that is that is
maintained its covid pop on pricing and
you don't see it coming down now's not
the time to buy a house Now's the Time
is to lease as if as efficiently as you
can and save your money if you're
fortunate to be in a market where maybe
prices are coming back down a little bit
now I sound like sauce because he's
right and the reason I sound like sauce
is because on this point Adam is 100
right save that it's okay to rent it's
okay to save that money and wait for a
good time to buy
yeah not on that being said after
everything from listening from you and
listening to Pat and listen to what you
said about your friend I feel
comfortable asking if I could borrow 25
000 shirts from you no problem thanks
Adam I appreciate it you know you know
when you when you you say something
about
17 uh prices down in San Francisco more
than 330 billion dollars of equity lost
in San Francisco that's a lot of money
330 billion dollars in value lost in San
Francisco right hey if you enjoyed this
short hope you want to watch the whole
thing click over here but if you want to
make 2023 the beginning of the greatest
years of your life I host a conference
once year it's called The Vault
conference where 3 000 CEOs executive
entrepreneurs from around the world come
together to strategize for three and a
half days this year it's going to be at
Miami Diplomat Resort and the speakers
this year is going to be Tom Brady he'll
be there I'll be interviewing them Mike
Tyson will gudara the guy that ran 11
Madison in New York if you run a
business if you're a CEO entrepreneur
and executive this is not an event you
want to miss out on get yourself your
spouse your business partner your
running mates registered and I look
forward to seeing you there click on the
link here or see the link in the
description and I hope to spend three
and a half days with you in Miami in
August and September take care everybody
foreign
[Music]